did you know that Stephanie Meyer wanted
Henry Cavill to play Edward this is who
we'd pick if we could have our fantasy
casting for the new Twilight series
Robert Pattinson famously made fun of
the role when he was playing Edward
Cullen oh my God okay I'm 108 years old
and to be fair it is a pretty unique
part he's a 108 year old vampire in the
body of a 17 year old for Edward we're
going to need someone with a mature Heir
but a youthful look we are recommending
timote chalamet it's supposed to be too
much best known for his roles and call
me by your name and ladybird he has the
dramatic chops to be able to sell that
he's an ancient creature stuck repeating
high school plus he has that extra
smolder factor that would serve him well
in a part like this but let's turn our
attention to the guy who started it all
for Edward this one goes back to what
the woman in charge said not Bella
though we'll be getting to her soon
Stephanie Meyer Carlisle is the head of
the Cullen Clan as their makeshift
father he's responsible for bringing
everyone together he has to be a little
bit mysterious but wise and played by
someone who would be able to give a lot
of heart to the role for that we're
thinking Henry Cavill Stephanie said
back in 2007 that Henry was the only
actor I've ever seen who I think could
come close to pulling off Edward Cullen
but she even later admitted that he
might be a little too old to pull it off
at this point so instead she suggested
that Cavill would make a great Carlisle
and we couldn't agree more Bella Swan is
another one of those tricky roles to
cast we need an actress who can seem
awkward in her skin despite having that
star quality that makes you gravitate
right to her Kristen Stewart played the
part beautifully in the movies but for
this new series we're suggesting actress
Lana Condor best known as Lara Jean in
to all the boys I've Loved Before okay
it was a long time ago her unique
balance of charm and approachability
makes her the perfect candidate to play
Bella I can imagine myself doing it Lana
even praised Kristen once for the way
that she held the entire movie on her
back we wonder how Taylor Lautner felt
about all that when you think about it
Jacob is a pretty demanding role we're
looking for an actor who's believably
young and shy in the beginning before
blossoming into his full-on wolfy self
once we get to New Moon Forest good luck
may still be an up-and-coming actor but
considering he was taking home awards
for his role in the Revenant when he was
just 18. we think he can handle it
Forest also has Native American ancestry
and and an important part of Jacob's
story includes the fact that he's part
of the quillute tribe but beyond that
Forest just has that star quality that
makes him the perfect match from Bella's
shape-shifting best friend but Jacob is
far from Bella's only friend in Forks
Jessica is Bella's first friend in Forks
I'm Jessica by the way she's a cheery
girl first played by Anna Kendrick who
apparently forgot she was even in
Twilight movies according to Twitter we
love Anna but this time around we're
thinking someone who has a bit more
experience playing the bubbly best
friend to an introvert your costumes in
the tent
costume you've seen Emma Myers playing
Wednesday's roommate on the Netflix
series Wednesday and we can see her
giving Bella a heartfelt welcome to
Forks but we all know it's just a matter
of time before Bella gets involved with
the Cullen Clan now you gotta feel bad
for Jasper as the newest addition to the
Colin Clan Jasper has the least amount
of control over his bloodlust bit of a
tortured Soul who needs an actor who can
portray some depth and after seeing
Austin Butler's performance as Elvis
really what I dream of we think he could
be up for the challenge Austin naturally
has the same blonde hair and blue eyes
as Jasper too but in order for him to
really shine he's going to need the
right actress to play his girlfriend
Alice what sort of actress do you see in
Alice's future we're thinking she has to
be able to play pretty bubbly sort of
like the way amandlas Denberg came
across in everything everything also has
a long history with movies based on
books considering she took on the role
of Rue in the first Hunger Games movie
when she was only 14 years old she she
even attended the premieres for breaking
dawn part 1 and 2 so she's clearly a fan
we can see her taking well to the role
of Bella's almost sister but let's
switch gears and talk about Bella's
actual family for a minute here poor
Charlie he means well in the books but
he doesn't always know the best thing to
say and he may be better suited to his
job as a cop than he is to being a
father still we're going to need an
actor who's able to portray a lot of
emotion possible and we think that David
Harbor may just do the trick he's played
a police officer on stranger things
before a show where he also has a pretty
heartfelt relationship with a daughter
figure as well I can fight better than
any of us but let's get back to the
Colin clan for a bit and talk about a
Vampire who's become known as a bit of a
himbo among the fandom Emmett is the
biggest and toughest of the colon clan
for that we're gonna need an actor who's
physically intimidating enough to sell
it Noah centineo proved he was able to
tough it alongside the Rock in Black
Adam but he's all also shown off his
more comedic side as petered in all the
boys I've Loved Before you have the
references of an 80 year old woman Not
only would Noah look good alongside
Rosalie who will be casting in just a
moment here but he'd also be able to
handle Emmett's sense of humor Rosalie
may seem like a mean girl but don't let
first appearances fool you as the series
goes on you come to see that there's a
lot more going on with her than meets
the eye still looking for an actress who
seems a little too good to be real sort
of like Grace Van Deen who you might
recognize as cheerleader Chrissy from
season four of stranger things she
definitely has the kind of acting chops
we're gonna need to handle some of
Rosalie's more emotional scenes do you
ever feel like
you're losing your mind still one last
member of the Cullen clan for us to cast
if Carlisle is the head of the Cullen
family then Esme is definitely the heart
deaf mother to everyone and even becomes
a bit of a mother to Bella herself which
is something she's going to need if
she's going to defend herself against
our next entry for Esme we need an
actress who's able to capture her loving
and nurturing quality which is why we
think Lashana Lynch might be a good fit
you may recognize Lashana from the
Netflix musical adaptation of Matilda
where she played MIss honey I believe
your mind is extraordinary Matilda's
loving and nurturing teacher Victoria is
a bit of a sleeper villain she seems
innocent enough when you first meet her
outside of the company she keeps more on
them later but as the series goes on we
find out that she's a force to be
reckoned with for her we imagine that we
are going to need an actress who's
already pretty experienced playing on
the dark side plus it would probably
help if she already had Victoria's
distinctive red hair Sophie Turner
checks all of these boxes having already
played a little bit of a bad guy in
X-Men dark Phoenix you want this power
Laurent tries to act as the voice of
reason he may turn on our heroes
eventually when Edward leaves Bella
unprotected but I can't help myself he
lost so mouth-watering but in the first
book he's the one to warn Our Heroes
when our next entry is on their Trail in
some ways it's similar to the role
Corbin blue plays in the movie that made
us love him High School Musical even the
drama Geeks and The Brainiac suddenly
think that they can talk to us Corbin
Moore recently appeared on High School
Musical the musical the series which
makes us think that a huge Revival is in
the works for his career Victoria and
Laurent may show some restraint but
James is a full-on animal he's the
villain of the first book but there's a
lot of room for an actor to bring their
own take on the role and we'd like to
see Alex Saxon take a crack at it his
role as hacker Ace in the CW Nancy Drew
series proves that Alex can definitely
make James a convincing threat plus Alex
saxon's first role was in the TV series
awkward playing a character named
vampire guy we figure he might
appreciate coming full circle and
playing a vampire again as much as we
loved the cast of the original movies
we're getting pretty excited to see who
the new series places in these roles do
you agree with our casting choices or is
there another actor you can think of who
would do a better job as your favorite
character we are all twyhearts here so
make sure to let us know down below